[Musique]
psm risque 12 ans est la nouvelle recrue
d'illicite dance la compagnie saint
quentinois a fait danser tous les âges
depuis 1995 son fondateur c'est lui au
la civi illicites vraiment au départ
donc il ya 22 ans quand j'ai quitté
black blanc beur et que j'ai pris la
décision de me monter cette structure
mon objectif était d'avoir une structure
structure un peu intermédiaire je
trouvais que pour arriver dans le milieu
professionnel il y avait un pas immense
on devait quitter la banlieue arrivée
sur paris connaître personne donc je me
suis dit je vais mettre une structure en
place qui va pouvoir former
professionnellement les jeunes les
jeunes qui ont envie de devenir
professionnel et leur apporter une vraie
rigueur une vraie discipline
mais il y cite c'est avant tout une
compagnie professionnelle
aujourd'hui sept danseurs la composent
et faut vivre ce style au niveau
national et international
il ya une des chorégraphes qui
travaillent avec moi adeline qui à la
chorégraphe de la compagnie
professionnelle qui a brillé sur
plusieurs plateaux télé et qui a été
aussi une danseuse sélectionnées pour
faire la publicité avec beyoncé pour
l'oréal il y avait trois danseuses de
suez à dîner était dessus donc une
grande fierté pour moi donc je me suis
dit ma petite formation de banlieue
n'est pas si décalé que ça et puis après
il y en a eu d'autres qui ont gagné des
concours internationaux
après une pause d'un an la compagnie
repart sur les chemins de la création
son prochain projet le chorégraphie pour
la ryder cup la compétition
internationale de gauche qui aura lieu à
saint quentin en yvelines en septembre